this is a production of Cornell
University hey guys and I've got a few
things I want to go through but mostly
this is just information for you so if
you have questions at any time you know
stop I'll be happy to talk as much as
you guys want about any particular topic
so basically I'll start telling you a
little bit about myself so you know my
family didn't have a lot of people that
went to college you know we had a few
that ended up in nursing school but
certainly nobody went to grad school so
I was really interested in science in
high school I loved biology what do you
do when you like science in high school
right I didn't know so I thought okay
I'll try to be a doctor because that's
what you do and you don't know anything
about academia or research or science so
I went to school you know thinking I was
a pre-med and then the more I get into
it the more I learned the more I thought
well maybe that's not for me so I
volunteered in a hospital and at the
same time I got a job working in a lab
on campus doing research with
streptococcus mutans which probably most
of you have in your mouth right now
causes cavities hopefully not in your
mouth right now and I absolutely loved
the microbiology research and I
absolutely hated working in the hospital
I'm still not really fond of hospitals
and so the idea of being a doctor it
just was like no way
and but the more I got into the research
the more I realized I loved it and so
then you know from there it's like I got
an advisor and I was working with
somebody in the lab you know professor
was very helpful and he said yeah you
know there's lots of things you can do
with a PhD in microbiology you know you
can do all of these interesting things
and so I went to grad school and I
didn't think I wanted to be a professor
when I went to grad school I thought I
wanted to work in the biotech industry
in particular I wanted to clean up
contamination in the environment using
microbes but then as I learned more
about myself and as I learned more about
microbiology I realized I was really
fascinated in microbial ecology and what
happens in soils and that basically led
me to our am today and so that's part of
the process of like deciding if you want
to go to grad school or figuring out
what you want to do right now is getting
experiences so getting internships like
maybe
the Botanical Garden or somewhere else
you know taking time to figure out what
excites you and narrowing down the list
of things you want to do with your life
right I mean that's hopefully what you
guys are thinking about right now and
maybe I'll be able to help you a little
bit but my job today is mostly to give
you some idea about what grad school is
all about and if you're interested in it
how you might get in so there's a few
things I want to cover what is grad
school all about why would you want to
go to grad school what you can do to
prepare to go to grad school and then
how that whole admissions process works
and I'll sort of take them on in that
order so what is grad school grad school
is it's basically training to become
good at doing research right grad school
is much more focused than undergraduate
so an undergraduate you're doing credits
you know you're taking courses primarily
they're other things you're doing of
course but you're getting your degree
because of the coursework and credits
that you're taking you know there's 120
credits you got to take and you got to
satisfy all these criteria that doesn't
really exist in grad school grad school
is about doing some kind of original
research right it's like finding
something where you're going to make an
individual impact in a new way
and yes you take courses in grad school
but they're very flexible and there
aren't many of them it's mostly focused
on a real practical experience alerting
exercise and the real goal of grad
school you know you're gonna have some
focused area that you're becoming an
expert in but the real unifying theme is
you're learning how to learn you're
learning how to how to design research
how to perform research and how to
answer a question that it's not
something you can just look up in a book
right there's lots of questions out
there that we don't have the answers to
going to grad school is getting the
skills it takes to be able to answer
those questions you just can't look up
in a textbook so maybe you can write
your own textbook someday so in terms of
grad school there's a few different
degrees you might hear about or think
about there's a MPS degree which is a
master's of professionals
these professional service studies this
is a little bit less common in the
sciences typically it's more coursework
focused it's usually a shorter program
one or two years and usually it's for
somebody you know if you're interested
in going into industry and you want to
be a CEO for a company that makes
fertilizer or one of these big AG
biotech companies like Bayer crop
sciences or something like that and you
know you're gonna be a manager but you
really want to know a lot about soil
science so you can understand what the
people who work for you are doing that
might make sense to do an NPS in soil
science for example so you're focusing
on a particular area to improve your
knowledge in that area but you're not
going to go on to be a professor in that
topic right it's much more focused
master's degree is very much still a
research degree you know but what you're
doing there is sort of learning how to
be a scientist maybe more than learning
how to direct a research program so if
you want to be able to direct a research
program either in industry or academia
you really need the PhD so the PhD is
sort of like you know you're able to
identify new research topics design a
research program to answer that question
get the funding to do it manage it and
then get a positive outcome whereas with
a master's degree it's more like well
you're able to do research but you might
not be in a position to sort of come up
with new ideas or sort of direct the
whole research program any questions
about those sort of different degrees a
master's is usually two maybe three
years a PhD can vary the fastest I've
seen somebody finishes like four and a
half years and the longest I've seen
somebody take was eight years eight year
student spent a lot of time abroad and
he did lots of interesting things so he
was using his time well
that's a good question so so that varies
by field and so what I'll and so there
are there are slight cultural
differences and practices across
different fields so if you're a
microbiologist or a plant biologist or a
chemist
you're gonna see some differences so in
general the way I like to describe it is
if you're in a laboratory based
environment like you're doing bench work
in the lab all day
those people typically go right from the
bachelor's degree to a PhD right they
don't usually get a masters whereas
people who do field work you know either
ecology Natural Resources Plant Sciences
those people it's more likely that
you're going to get a master's degree
before you get the PhD and it might be
more expected that you do so plant
science is kind of funny because we've
got the some of the plant biologists or
like doing genomics in the lab all day
and then we've got people in
horticulture who are out in the field
all day and so you're generally gonna
see you know those field people it's
more common that they'll have a master's
before the PhD whereas the bench people
it's almost exciting almost consistently
everybody just gets the PhD without a
master's so to some degree it varies and
I and my own personal I don't have never
heard a good explanation for why that is
but the best guess I have is that if
you're in a if you're in a bench science
program you know most of those research
jobs tend to be directing research
rather than performing it and so if you
want a direct research you need a PhD
and so a master's degree isn't quite as
marketable if you're in a bench type
environment whereas in those field based
environments there are many more sort of
management level positions whether with
government or extension where that
master's degree is a pretty marketable
thing and so I feel like it's kind of
market driven but yeah that is what it
is but so if you have an adviser if
you're thinking about grad school you
know in a particular area that you know
you should ask or try to figure out what
the particulars are for that area
so why might you want to go to grad
school number one you should you know in
the sciences you should really like
science and really be interested in
research but there are some other good
reasons so there's a good reason in
terms of salary if that sort of thing is
interested interesting to you you know
there's sort of this old saw out there
that you know if you get too much
education it's hard to get a job or
maybe you educate yourself out of a job
and that's not true so if you look at
the statistics from the Bureau of Labor
Statistics which are national u.s.
statistics if you got a if you get a
doctoral degree not a medical degree but
a PhD over your lifetime you're likely
to get 43 percent more salary than if
you just have a bachelor's alone and the
unemployment rate at least as of 2015
for people with a PhD is 1.7 percent
which is about a third of the
unemployment rate for people who have a
bachelor's so if you have a PhD
you're more employable and you're going
to earn more money if that matters to
you and even with a master's the
unemployment rate for a master's is 2.4
percent which is like half of the
unemployment right right now for
everybody else and even with a master's
you're gonna get 18 percent higher
salary over your lifetime than someone
just with a bachelor's so if you're
interested in science you know if you're
thinking about you know these things are
important to you yeah it's a good idea
to think about grad school the other
thing is in the sciences it's mostly
free right so if you go to get a PhD if
you go to get a masters or a research
degree at a university generally you're
going to get your tuition covered so
your tuition is going to be paid for by
the program or by a fellowship or some
other method maybe a teaching
assistantship and you're going to
actually get paid to go to school so
you're gonna get a living stipend it's
not a ton of money but it's enough to
pay all your bills and cover your health
insurance and everything you need while
you're in school so it's a pretty good
deal you end up with getting your
education paid for you also end up
making more money over your lifetime and
you have a low
unemployment rate so if you think it's
something you're interested in you know
it can be a good choice any questions
about all that stuff alright so then the
other thing is how do you prepare right
so what can you do to prepare for grad
school in terms of preparing for grad
school and in terms of your application
I mean there are really three things
that you want to think about one of the
things is your coursework right you've
guys have already picked majors you're
thinking about majors you're thinking
about your concentration probably if
you're in the plant sciences major and
so that's going to really dictate your
coursework so that coursework is of
course important but probably the single
most important thing in terms of grad
school is is real-world experience so
like in my case you know I volunteered
in that Hospital I did that research in
the lab you know I joined the lab as a
junior and I worked throughout my junior
and senior years and I had one whole
summer where I was working on the
research real-world experiences so like
internships you know working in the lab
independent research credits honors
project it doesn't have to be just in
one lab but but those experiences are
going to help you to know you know what
you like and what interests you but
they're also going to really help to
give you the skills you're going to need
and sort of develop your background so
that you can get into graduate school if
that's a choice you want to make and
then the other thing to mention there in
terms of real-world experiences a lot of
people like to take a gap year so so you
get your bachelor's and then maybe
you're not ready to go right into grad
school or maybe for some reason you know
you think there's something you can
improve about your preparation for grad
school so a lot of people will get a job
you know it could be a job as a
technician it could be a job on a farm
some people go into the Peace Corps you
know those sorts of experiences if
they're related to your area of interest
you know if they're related to your
professional sort of educational goals
and why you're going
to grad school those kind of experiences
are generally going to help you write
because when you're making an
application for grad school those people
want to know are you really interested
in this
do you have skills and so you're gonna
develop that interest and get those
skills not just in the classroom and so
those real-world experiences are really
important and you know if you're a
freshman if you're a sophomore it's
definitely a good time to be thinking
about it if you're a transfer student
coming in maybe later on definitely you
want to try to get you know some of
those experiences as soon as possible
when there are lots of different ways to
do that
so the other thing I wanted to talk
about is admissions but before I start
talking about admissions you guys are
really quiet and I know you must have
some questions so does somebody because
I and I know that if you have a question
there are probably ten people in the
room who have the same question
so it would be really helpful maybe if
somebody would ask yeah so you you're
asking the question from the point from
your point of view like where do I want
to send my application yeah that's a
great question so yeah there's a ton of
programs out there and it can be hard to
navigate and I would say the first thing
you need to do is figure out what you
want you know what are your interests
you know that that old question that
people ask you that you hate to get what
you want to do what do you want to be
doing in 10 years right
you know you need the first thing you
need to do is be answer to answer that
question real well it's hard right and
that's why I say get experiences because
getting those experiences will help you
to answer that question you know you
have to know who you are before you know
where you want to go so if you have that
bit ready you know then I guess there
would be two things to do the first and
probably most valuable thing is
hopefully you've been working with
somebody in the lab maybe that's a
graduate student maybe it's a professor
maybe it's your academic adviser but
you've got somebody in a in a sort of
mentor kind of relationship you know
maybe it's Marvin here in this class
right but you've got somebody who you
can talk to who has a network right
they're a professional they know the
area if you go to that person and you
say hey I'm really interested in this
area of study you know they're going to
be able to tell you probably off the top
of your head okay here's half a dozen
programs you might think about applying
to and even if they don't they probably
know somebody who could give you that
list right so so tap into that network
when you when you're sort of doing
research you're developing a network of
professionals so tap into your network
and
them and they'll provide you really good
information yeah and if there are other
people you're working with you know
whether it's an internship or in a lab
you know the graduate students ask them
to write so you know sort of canvas your
your network and get information and
then the other thing is as you're as
you're interested in this area you
should be reading so as you get more and
more interested you want to do more and
more reading and if you're doing
research you're probably getting papers
to read maybe you're seeing scientific
papers and your classes or maybe you're
just reading stuff from the internet so
those articles are going to talk about
the science but you're also gonna see
the names of people who made those
discoveries write those names down write
when you see an article that has a
really exciting conclusion who's the
senior author on that you know what
institution are they at so keep a list
of the kinds of stuff that you find
exciting and then who did the work and
where are they
maybe they're all the people doing this
work or at the University of Minnesota
or something you know that's something
you want to know so if you're reading a
lot of papers and you find that all the
papers you're excited about are written
by like five people you should probably
apply the institution's for those five
people are at write so those are really
good and then the web you know and then
you look online that can be harder but
you know if you look for plant science
programs you know not every place in the
country has one so you find the ones
that do if you're interested in a
particular area you know look at the
faculty bios and find a place like you
might look at the Michigan State and if
you're interested in a particular area
maybe they have only one person really
specializing and when you read their
background it looks really lame and
maybe you look at UC Davis and they have
five people in that area and they're all
really dynamic right then you'd want to
make that application there so I would
say use your network you know do some
reading you know and then and then do
that sort of web-based search yeah good
question you got a question
so that's tricky right so so there are a
couple
so funding is one of the big things and
we could talk a lot a long time about
this and it's an important thing for
grad school because you do get funded to
go to grad school but whether or not
that funding comes through is one of the
big things that dictates whether or not
you get accepted so when you're getting
accepted to an undergraduate program
mostly they're looking at like your
merit you know your your GPA the
coursework you did you know they're
looking at like that whole piece and
that's certainly important for grad
school but it's only one of the pieces
for grad school you know this funding
piece is really important because we
don't have unlimited funding we can't
just I'll pay for anybody to go to
school and so we have to sort of figure
out how to provide that money for you
and so so really in the bigger picture
there's three ways right there's
fellowships
there's teaching assistantships and then
there are faculty grants and and these
all three of these are the mechanisms we
used to fund students and when you're
admitted you might be admitted with one
kind of support but over the course of a
PhD you might actually move between all
three and if I admit ten students it's
unlikely that all ten of those students
will have the same kind of funding
package so with fellowships there are
two basic kinds I would say there's
kinds that you apply for and they're the
kinds that the school you're applying to
will nominate you for so the ones that
you apply for you have control over but
there aren't a ton of them so there's
like the biggest one that you guys
should all know about is the National
Science Foundation graduate fellowship
program so that's a really big program
it's competitive but if you get funded
there it's fantastic right you can
almost guarantee that you're going to
get accepted anywhere you apply if you
get one of these NSF fellowships the due
dates are usually in the fall so you
want to plan ahead but I would very much
if you think about going to grad school
you really want to look at this and
think carefully about making an
application but there are other things
like the Ford Foundation has fellowship
program
I notice USAID still have fellowship
programs but there's a lot of programs
out there and you sort of have to look
around they tend to be specialized NSF
is very broad but but there are a lot of
specialized programs I want to say the
armed services have some fellowship
programs maybe than some of the national
labs do so you have to hunt around the
one I would recommend because it's broad
and almost anybody could apply for it is
the NSF program so if you apply for your
own funding and you get that from that
external agency that travels with you no
matter where you go and that's fantastic
short of that you don't have to have
that you can apply to school the school
can nominate you for a fellowship like
an internal fellowship so Cornell has a
lot of internal fellowships we use for
recruiting purposes and so like as the
director of Graduate Studies I get your
application if I see your application
I'm like oh this would be a great
candidate for this funding you know I'm
gonna nominate you for that you won't
even know I nominated you for that if
they don't accept you then okay I'll try
to fund you some other way but if they
do then I'll send you a letter that says
congratulations you know you've received
this fellowship you know please come to
Cornell so you don't necessarily know
that that's happening but that's one way
that we could fund you so that's sort of
fellowships and then the teaching
assistantship so faculty teach we teach
courses and so we need assistance with
that and so teaching assistantships are
a way that the university pays graduate
students so that for some of their time
they're helping with teaching and it's
capped at how many hours a week you can
be expected to be teaching I think the
maximum is like 15 hours for most
assignments in reality you spend
spending a lot less time than that
actually teaching but but that would be
a way to sort of pay your salary and
tuition as well in the sciences you do a
little bit less of that if you are in
the humanities they actually usually
have to that they don't have as many
fellowships and and grants as we do in
the sciences usually and so they can
spend a lot more teaching but but ta
ships aren't that onerous in the
sciences you
but so that's one way I might be able to
provide your funding is my unit might
have five or six ta lines and so that
means five or six people I can support
with those ta lines and again you
wouldn't know anything about that you're
gonna make the application I know I have
so many slots I'm gonna try to put
people in them and then the faculty
grants so Cornell doesn't give faculty
any money to do research right they give
us space and offices but that's it
when we get hired they give us some
money to buy equipment but then they
don't give us any more money
so after that if you want to do research
you need to get grants so National
Science Foundation USDA AG and food
research initiative Department of Energy
you know NASA you know international
agencies we need to hustle to get grant
money to support our research the
biggest component of that money is
usually people you know it's salaries
its tuition its health insurance and so
that's how we pay for a lot of grad
students so but that's tricky because
many of these funding programs might
reject ninety percent of the
applications that you make and so a
faculty member is constantly submitting
grant applications and they can't always
predict when and want is going to be
funded and maybe to get funded just by
chance right so one year that faculty
member might need to admit to students
and then the next year they might admit
none or maybe three years in a row they
might admit none so so that's a source
of funding but it's also somewhat
unpredictable so when you make an
application you know I can't tell you
where your money is going to come from
but I need to have a source of money to
admit you whether it's a fellowship or a
teaching assistantship or a faculty
grant and there's a lot that goes on
there so I'm happy to answer any
follow-up questions
any other questions good so in terms of
then in terms of Admissions and getting
into graduate school I would say that
really there are sort of three pieces to
that the the one piece is sort of the
merit of the applicant sort of what you
bring to the equation the second piece
is something I would call your fit with
the program and the third piece is the
funding and I think we already talked a
little bit about the funding funding is
usually a big constraint so I would say
that you know we usually get more
applicants who are who are high quality
and and the other thing I would say is
that at the graduate level you know if
you if I if I think there's a reasonable
likelihood that you're gonna be
successful in graduate school I'd like
to be able to admit you right I mean
obviously we use merit as a criteria we
want the best and brightest but but
really I'm only going to exclude you for
sure if I don't think you're gonna be
successful in graduate school if I think
you're going to be successful I want to
try to admit you and so but the reason I
can't admit everybody is usually funding
right so funding puts a cap on who we
can admit and then we're trying to admit
the people who have the highest merit
and have the best fit and we can talk
about merit in a second but this fit
thing is interesting because you know
gets back to the question you had
earlier about where do you apply right
so let's say you know maybe you didn't
do your homework when you decided where
to apply and you applied to a university
and you're really interested in let's
say you're really interested in using
drones to you know measure plant health
in some way right which is a cool thing
to do and you apply to a university
where there's absolutely nobody working
with drones right and they look at your
application and they're like holy crap
this person has an NSF fellowship you
know they have a 4.0 GPA they've got
this wonderful internship and they want
to work with drones we don't have
anybody doing anything with drones do
you think they should admit you
they probably would not be doing you any
favors by admitting you because if they
admit you they might they might admit
you because you're just a great
applicant you have your own money and
they might hope that they could convince
you to work on something other than
drones but if they don't have a faculty
member working on drones and if that's
what your heart beats for you really
have no business going to that school
right so they should reject you because
there's no fit they don't have somebody
who can properly advise you and direct
you and mentor you in the area that
makes you excited you know what you're
trying to learn and so I would say that
in general fit is important so if you're
applying to a school and they don't have
expertise in that area that can be a
problem so more often what happens is
you might be applying and let's say they
do have somebody working on drones but
that person is going to retire in a few
years and because they're retiring in a
few years they're not taking students
again you know you're not likely to get
accepted because they can't suit you
know there's going to be nobody there to
work with you
you know let's say there's a couple of
people working at that program but both
of them just took five students last
year and they can't possibly take
another student you know they're not
going to be able to admit you right
because they want you to work with those
people if those people can't take
students you're not going to get
accepted right so this fit question
they're going to look at your
application and try to figure out you
know who with this university would the
student be best suited to work with and
if they can't find anybody who's well
suited to advise you then they're not
going to admit you right even if you're
a great student even if you have funding
you know they need to have that fit
piece and sometimes it's hard for you as
an applicant to predict that but you can
help yourself by doing your research
right if you're applying to a place that
there's only one person doing that
research or no people doing that
research you probably might want to be
careful about that
whereas if there's like five or six
people all doing the same thing your
odds of making a match are much better
right if there's only one person by all
means reach out to that person say hey
you know I think your research is great
I want to make an application you know
are you taking students at the moment
do you have funding for new students at
the moment and if they say wow this is
great I would love to have a student but
I haven't had a grant in 20 years and I
have no idea how I would fund you that's
a red flag right you know you might
think let's not make an application
there so you can sort of weight things
in your favor by doing your legwork
right you can look at that who's there
how many people are there you can reach
out to them you don't have to like ask
them to make a commitment all you have
to say is are you do you think you'll be
likely to take students next year you
know do you have funding for a new
student at this time and it's possible
faculty are busy they might not get back
to you but it's an easy question and so
most often they'll say yeah you know
there's a good chance I might be taking
someone and then you sort of put that in
your notes and you say okay that's a
good school to apply to so so the
funding the fit and then and then the
merit so the merit I mean the the pieces
of the application that relate to merit
or your coursework right GPA is an
important thing in getting into grad
school but probably not as important as
getting into undergrad I would say
there's a wide range of GPAs that we
accept into graduate school and
partially we're not as concerned about
GPA just because you don't spend as much
time in the classroom you know what we
want to know is are you going to be
successful in research you know the book
learning isn't as important anymore we
are very interested in what courses
you've taken so if you've taken really
easy classes if you've sort of not taken
important classes that we think are
crucial to getting into grad school in
our area that's going to be more of a
problem than if your GPA was a little
bit lower than a 4.0 right and you guys
are all going in the right direction
because you're plant sciences majors you
know got good core requirements you know
you're doing the background that you
would need to get into a lot of
different programs in the sciences so
that's probably not going to be an issue
for you so there's coursework you know
we do look at GRE scores right but Giri
scores again we don't expect perfect GRE
scores you know most of the students we
admit tend to be in the top quartile but
but people below and you're not in the
top quartile can
we'll get accepted it's sort of a
balancing game you know if you have a
really high GPA but your GRE is a little
lower you know that's probably gonna be
okay
so those are two components we look at
but neither one of them are sort of
determinative in its own right and then
the letters of recommendation are really
important right and so this is why again
you want to have real-world experiences
because if you take a course with
somebody and they you know they you're
one of 200 people and you know they can
say oh they did really well on the final
that's not a really good letter of
recommendation right whereas if you do
an internship or a research experience
where you're working with that person
closely over a whole semester or maybe
multiple semesters that person's gonna
be able to write a much better letter
that recommends you for who you are for
your capabilities and your strengths and
your interests and so getting to know
you know professionals is a good way to
be able to get good letters of
recommendation and then the last part of
your application itself is your your
statement of purpose and so you have to
write a statement when you get into
undergrad - but that's a little bit more
of kind of like an essay I think the
statement of purpose for grad school you
know I like to describe it as more like
you know it's more you telling your
story it's you talking about where
you're coming from and where you're
going and filling in the gaps in between
so what I like to say with a statement
of purpose and going to grad school is
you're trying to convince the admissions
committee that you're really interested
and passionate in this area that you're
trying to get a degree in and that
you're well prepared to be successful in
that endeavor so usually you want to
start off with where you're coming from
so how did you learn about this topic so
you guys are all interested in plant
sciences so you might say oh I got
interested in plant sciences because I
had this really remarkable experience
once that involved a plant right and so
whatever that is anybody why are you
guys in plant sciences
did anybody have a formative experience
or it's like this is the only thing the
cows would accept you for yeah why'd you
guys pick plant sciences death by the
pool yeah that would be a superb way to
start that kind of statement yeah
somebody else yeah
yeah why can't you be a florist oh okay
okay and they wanted more and better
things okay good awesome time pathology
there you are yeah sure and these are
all great right so this is how you sort
of start talking about it you know it's
your interaction with professionals
right your real-world experiences you
know these are the things that ground
you and you say hey this is how I got
excited and then the next step is what
did you do with that information so okay
I applied to one of the best schools in
the world to study plant sciences you
know I went there and I worked with
professionals and I did these research
experiences and I understood that you
know this is really what I want to do I
want to learn about plant pathogens or I
want to learn about agronomy and I took
coursework and I did this internship and
then I did this other internship right
and so you're sort of telling your story
and then you say and what I've really
realized is I want to do X you know you
then sort of project forward you say in
10 years 15 years I want to win the
World Food Prize by you know increasing
productivity of something or other
right so you project forward what you
want to be and you say to get there what
I really need is a PhD in plant sciences
from your school all right so you're
telling that story so where did you
start what's your interest how did that
interest grow how did you develop your
skill set where do you want to get and
why is the degree at this program that
you're targeting the natural inevitable
next step for you on your trajectory to
a Nobel Prize unfortunately we don't
have a lot of Nobel Prizes and the plant
sciences you can get them you can get
them a little harder yeah so that
statement of purpose is important and
it's also important in terms of telling
your own story if there's something in
your application package that you're
worried about or something that you want
to emphasize this is your chance right
if you're really proud of
thing you did you want to fit that in
there if there's something that was
really important you want to fit that in
if there's something you're really
nervous about I mean it's quite common
that you know maybe you had a real hard
time in that organic chemistry class or
maybe you know you got a D in calculus
that would be me sorry but maybe maybe
you did badly on the GRE test right you
don't want to ignore that because
somebody's gonna see it right but you
can tell your own story you can say you
know I got a D because you know it was
really a big adjustment you know going
to college and my girlfriend dumped me
and my grandma died and all this bad
stuff happened but you know the next
semester I turned it around and got
straight A's you know so I owned that
and I made sure I doubled down and I
improved so then you take this thing
that looks like a weakness and you turn
it into a strength in a story of
personal development right and so the
statement of purpose lets you do that so
I think frankly that's the first thing I
look at when I look at an application
because if somebody is passionate and
committed about what they're doing and
they know who they are that's usually
pretty obvious as soon as I read that
and if they're just adrift and they
don't know what they want to do and
they're going to grad school because
they don't know what else to do that's
obvious too so that statement is
something I think that's really
important but those other components are
the you know statement the GRE is the
coursework and very much well I guess
your letters of recommendation and then
that real world experience piece so
we're going to look for that but that'll
also help you to write that letter good
other questions about grad school or
applications I'm so you brought up what
I'm grad school they're like this word
whatever color
hmm so it's that that can vary I mean it
you you really you have to look and read
the description of what the fellowship
is all about number one and think about
it and then I would take that fellowship
application to some professional you
work with or an advisor and get their
opinion on it and then all of those
programs are going to have some kind of
coordinator or project manager or
program officer and I would very much
touch base with that person you know it
might be that those guidelines are
really straightforward and you feel
comfortable if you have any question or
even if you think it might be helpful
you know it's okay to contact the person
in charge of that program and say hey
this is who I am this is what I'm
interested in you know can you give me
advice in what you're looking for you
know is this suitable and that can be
very helpful right rarely ever would
that be detrimental so that can help to
get information so each program has
different you know some of them are
designed for you know maybe they're
designed for trying to enhance the
number of people doing international
research or you know people with a
certain background you know NSF tends to
have different focus areas like biology
or chemistry or engineering so you'd
want to sort of suss that out yeah yeah
yeah I mean the other thing you could do
I don't know we must have these
resources at Cornell certainly for NSF
but you can find out sort of who who has
gotten these awards in the past and you
should be able to sort of figure out
sort of you know you know get some sense
as to how those people have been
successful I know we have a few programs
that are aimed to trying to help
students get those NSF fellowships but
they're sort of all over campus so I'm
not sure that I could point you towards
one
where should I start
so you can take it as many times as you
want hi
the only score that you really see in
the application is the highest score so
they don't show you like every time
you've taken the test usually they show
you the highest score so if you get a
low score and you want to take it again
there's really no penalty because if you
do worse it's not going to show up if
you do better it will and the bad one
will go away I mean it costs money and
time and effort to do that so you don't
just take it 20 times but no I mean you
can take it when you feel like you're
ready it's not it's not really it's not
a real heavy content based exam you know
so it's kind of like the SAT in that
regard where it doesn't require a lot of
coursework you know you don't have to
have like knowledge and the plant
sciences to do well on that test it is
unfortunately one of these things where
test prep makes a difference so you know
getting a book and reading about
questions practice questions if you want
to take a course on how to do it those
those things do help but but yeah early
and often potentially you know there's
there's no downside I think to doing
that
they in the past they have had some
Subject Tests you know we never get
those scores and so I we don't require
them it used to be that some
universities did I don't even know if
they still offer those but they have in
the past had some so so if so generally
they're not required if your program
requires it you'll actually see you know
and that's a good reason to look out you
know for what programs you're interested
in because there might be a particular
program you want that requires a
particular subject test but in general
no they're not no not a lot of programs
I'm familiar with and particularly in
the plant sciences I'm not aware of
anybody who would require a subject test
just the general GRE
I've covered most of the things I want
to talk about so do you guys I mean do
you have other questions so so what grad
school is all about I guess I didn't
talk a whole lot about what you can do
with a grad degree that's something we
should talk about but preparing for
graduate school or getting admitted
anybody anybody have any suggestions
what can you actually do with a PhD
besides be a professor because you can
be a professor you have to get a PhD if
you want to be a professor what else do
you do with a PhD what are people with
PhDs do anybody know anybody know
anybody who's not a professor at Cornell
who has a PhD yeah what does he do mud
mud floods MD PhD oh so so are they a
sort of academic like professors or are
they actually doing just research not
just research okay good you know it's
actually it's sort of ironic but if you
get a PhD you can look at the salaries
of PhDs and then you can look at the
salaries of I'm sorry MDS and PhDs PhDs
always get less than md's which we're
not disgruntled about that at all but if
you get an MD and a PhD you actually get
less money than if you had just an MD it
gives you a sense of how the MDS think
about the phd's right if you get the PhD
they're like ah come on what's wrong
with you anybody else anybody knows
somebody with a graduate degree and what
they do for a living yeah
Oh super cool so that's you know very
much you know sort of a business kind of
environment so it like aerospace stuff
yeah that's super cool so my my I was
the first person in my family to go to
grad school but mine one of my cousins
you know she actually went to the
military and then she got a master's in
physics so she's working in a hospital
now working on these giant machines that
image your body you know sort of look
basically repairing them and make sure
whom they work properly which is kind of
cool it's not aerospace yeah so so
academia is pretty common I think boy
you know I think I had some statistics
on this yeah so like 30 to 50% of your
PhDs are going to be academic you know
professors or instructors of some sort
about twenty to thirty percent or in the
private sector so like Boeing one of my
PhD students is working at Bayer crop
sciences he's working in their sort of
genomic research area so he's doing
genome analyses of plants and microbes
to try and find things that are valuable
for the company you know I've got other
people who came through my program who
are working at biotech startups in
agriculture or biotechnology kind of
industries so a lot of people get
research either research administration
or sales or technical or data positions
or even writing a lot of PhDs
you know you get a lot of writing skill
doing a PhD and those scientific writing
skills are quite marketable so about 20
to 30 percent of PhDs are in the private
sector maybe about five to ten percent
in government so we have a lot of
scientists and particularly plant
sciences and EPA USDA NRCS the National
Science Foundation USGS even the
Department of Energy right so so these
these government agencies employ a lot
of scientists right and so that's
opportunities nongovernmental
organizations as well there are
international research organizations or
sort of conservation organizations that
you
get a job with with a PhD so there's
lots out there in fact probably the
majority of jobs are outside of academia
but they're all related to research and
and sometimes they may not even you know
you get a PhD in the plant sciences
you know the skill set you have of
course it's a natural for you to get a
job relating to plant sciences or
agricultural biotechnology but that
skillset translates in a lot of ways so
you know there are jobs and like you
could get jobs probably in the Patent
Office right if you've got this
knowledge you know they need people with
knowledge because you're patenting stuff
that relates to plant science all the
time and so somebody with a PhD and the
plant sciences would be marketable there
you also have that skill set in terms of
research maybe that data analytics
there's a lot of big data and plant
sciences and if you know how to work
with big data a lot of the ways you work
with data whether it's DNA sequence data
or census data or some corporate kind of
data you know those computer skills are
going to translate pretty well so so
even if you're going into the graduate
degree in the plant sciences of course
you probably like plant sciences you
know but that degree is still somewhat
flexible you know you're not you're not
necessarily pigeon-holed and there are a
lot of and that's why the unemployment
rate for PhDs is so darn low
good yeah
that's a great question
that's a great question and I would say
yes and no so I think where you go where
you go is probably somewhat less
important than who you work with and so
the reason for that is because your
training is going to be very strongly
influenced by the program of the of the
person you're working with your mentor
they have a professional network they're
known for a certain thing they're good
at a certain thing and they're gonna be
training you in that area so if the
world expert in and using drones to
measure agronomic variables is at you
know Humboldt State in California not to
like to mean Humboldt State but but say
you're at Humboldt State you're probably
better off going to Humboldt State if
that's your area of interest rather than
like going to like a Harvard Stanford if
there's nobody doing that thing at
Harvard or Stanford I mean yeah you'd
have this fancy degree you know but if
you're interested is being a leader in
that area you want to get trained from
the leader in that area and
professionals know that you know like so
I'm a microbiologist I know you know
there aren't so many microbiologist out
there that I don't know the people in my
field I know them and so I know if you
came from a particular area I know
something about you you're gonna have
certain skills I'm gonna have certain
expectations and that's based on the
person not the place it might differ a
little bit if you're interested in
industry you know if you're working in
an area outside of your focus so if
you're in the plant sciences and you're
staying in the plant science is who you
work with is probably more important
than where you go but the further you
get away from that core discipline so if
you're getting a job in a biotech
industry where they don't know anything
about Plant Sciences or you want to get
a writing job you know they might be
more impressed by the place rather than
the person right so I won't say that the
place doesn't matter but it matters more
the further you get away from the focus
and the more you're maintaining that
focus probably the less the place
matters and more the person matters good
and that's again where as a student you
don't always know who the best people to
work with are but that's why you want to
develop a network while you're here at
Cornell because the people who you're
going to be working with your advisors
and the graduate students and the
postdocs they'll have a sense and
they'll be able to tell you oh if you're
interested in this you probably want to
work with one of these three or four
people yeah oh that's great yeah
starting your own companies that's
another thing yeah yeah and you want to
make your own job
we were having that gives you a level of
credibility yeah because you're able to
you know you're you've got a director
level position you can identify a
research project and then lead that
project and and whether that's in
academia or starting a company it's the
same same skill set I mean in a lot of
senses you know being a faculty member
is kind of like running a startup you
know cuz all of your funding comes
externally and that's like capital
investment right so you're basically
always drumming up capital to do your
research so there's a lot of
relationship between starting up the
small company and being an academic so
oddly enough and the science is at least
yeah yeah other questions again I think
I've covered everything I wanted to
cover there's probably a million
questions we could answer
yeah so I like to tell people you know
if you want to take it depends on what
you do with the time so so the best case
scenario if you're taking time off is
you're doing something that relates to
your area of interest so for example and
it might actually be strategically
important for you to do that so the best
case is let's say you came in as a
transfer student and let's say you
didn't have a lot of opportunities to do
research while you were here at Cornell
and you remembered you know Dan Buckley
at this talk told me that I should have
a lot of research experience before I go
to grad school okay well you know with
your undergraduate degree you can
probably get a job as a technician
either in a company or maybe in a
research lab somewhere on campus maybe
here at Cornell so then you work for a
year or two doing research in the plant
sciences something related to it doesn't
have to be exactly the same but
something close to what you're
interested in so then you apply for grad
school you're actually gonna be much
stronger you know with those two years
break then you would have been right out
of undergrad because now you're coming
with this background the skill set
another good letter of recommendation
and probably a stronger statement of
purpose because you you know better who
you are and what you want to do so to
the degree that that you take a gap year
or years and you're doing something
relevant and that's part of your story
part of your arc you know to get you
where you want to go then it's a great
idea if it's totally unrelated then it's
not as good of an idea right the longer
you're out of grad school doing
something that's not relevant to this
goal you know people are gonna be like
well what were you doing you know if
you're really interested in going to
grad school for X why did you spend five
years doing something totally different
you know I mean and maybe you have a
good reason for that maybe you can
justify it but it's going to raise some
question marks people are gonna be like
well why did you you know go mountain
climbing in the Andes for five years
what you really want to do is molecular
biology in the lab right so maybe your
mountain climbing in the Andes because
you're trying to find a rare plant that
you want to study you know the molecular
biology of then it make
sentence rate but but you just have to
think about how that fits into your
story anything else
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu